I got it in trouble when I was maybe
when I was maybe 15 16 years old I got
arrested for armed robbery with a with a
firearm I just didn't know better I grew
up in the family which I thought being a
gang was being part of being being a I
was at everyday life my grandma was a
gang member Michael was a gang gang
member I didn't know better you know I
live in a really nice neighborhood
thankfully and the people in my
neighborhood their kids have very good
lives very bright futures but everyone
knows that life is much harder for kids
who grow up in inner cities they often
come from poor single-parent homes and
too often get involved in gangs and
criminal activity
we went down to National City California
and met some really great people who
have devoted their lives to helping
at-risk kids in their neighborhood
national city is a very nice
neighborhood a lot of single-family
homes we do have a gang problem and we
have problems with drugs as in any other
community the community youth athletics
center pretty much started out in 1991
in the backyard of mr. Carlos Madigan
jr. and Carlos moyá
got a senior pretty soon we had so many
kids that we had to find a bigger
building with the help of ups and burrow
Nibbana Mission Indians we were able to
expand to the facilities that we have
now we handled about a thousand about a
thousand kids per year and there are all
addressed kids all these kids are kids
that have been kicked out of various
other programs they come to us they need
a family and we provide them that family
we provide them the guidance and we
provide them the ability to succeed in
life
my name is Jose Vargas I got involved in
the gym Holly approximately around 1997
after I was I released from Rancho del
Campo and now I'm applying for the
National City Police Department and
hopefully everything goes well hopefully
next time I talk to you guys I fast and
I'm a police officer there are many
benefits to the kids that come through
here the biggest benefit is that we will
not see these kids in the prison system
or the criminal justice system the cya
sea is a great example of ordinary
citizens taking responsibility for
improving their community
you think city officials would do
everything possible to support their
efforts but instead the city wants to
replace the gym with a swanky high-rise
condo Jeff Rose is an attorney for the
Institute for justice the non-profit
public interest law firm that represents
the cya see right here in National City
is really one of the most egregious
examples of the abuse of eminent domain
that I've encountered since I joined the
Institute for justice what they're
saying is this one we're gonna do and we
want you to cooperate with us if not
we're gonna eminent domain you and take
your property eminent domain as you
might know is the traditional power of
government to take property for a public
use really public use has traditionally
until about the end of the Second World
War really just meant a public use in
other words the government could take
your property for a road or a school or
a post office or a military base or a
public park if the city was coming in
and saying we're gonna build a road here
or we're gonna build something that's
going to benefit everybody I don't think
we could really fight with it but what
they're doing is lining the developer's
pockets and lining their pockets
Brad Ralston is the director of
redevelopment in National City
California there's two two key boundary
lines there's the redevelopment plan
area was the red line which was the
whole redevelopment area and then
there's the area within that where the
agency has the ability to use eminent
domain within that footprint of ability
to use eminent domain as I understand it
there are six or seven hundred parcels
in that area
the typical eminent domain story
a modest neighborhood or a modest
collection of small businesses that a
wealthy developer wants so the developer
can transform it into high-rise
condominiums or a big-box store I
believe our residents want redevelopment
they want to see their city you know
move forward
they don't necessarily engage in the
details of that such as eminent domain I
mean to be honest with you I'm not sure
that I'm not sure how many of the
residents would wouldn't know what that
even means
yes I'm my name is Sarah and Rica's I
asked president for three terms here at
the National City Eagles 27:12 and
the eminent domain concerns me very
deeply because of our roots here in in
National City and I think it's an
injustice
that not is only going on in National
City but throughout our country of
government officials and private
developers coming in and just wiping
this off the map - just right from the
very core of my heart I think it's wrong
to take away somebody's property when
they don't want to sell it it's anytime
you move it's a bad thing and this is my
street traffic for people who were on
the mile with cars
and we are the closest motorcycle shop
to the world's largest naval base how
many hours of sleep have I already lost
you know I've lost a ton of hours of
sleep you just sit there you can't what
are you gonna do there's enough
uncertainty in business anyway and then
literally not just pulling the rug out
from underneath you but pulling the
concrete slab in the land that you're
working and building on that makes it
tough you know so the benefits of
redevelopment are predominately economic
if all you're looking at is money and
that's it I'll agree with it that hey
you know what get rid of everybody here
but that's not what life's all about
that's not what this Constitution tells
us the argument against them in a domain
is an easy one to make because it's
fundamental to property rights which are
fundamental to you know the American Way
the American dream as you can see we
have a boxing ring we teach these kids
not to give up to fight for what they
believe it on June 19 2007 the cya CE
held a public rally to protest the
city's plans the government should not
be taking your hard-earned property and
your American dream to give to rich
people to build condos for other rich
people